yeah hi everyone here and uh watching
remotely
um when I submitted this proposal um it
was called GPT 3 incorporating gpt3 but
um since then there have been quite a
few other language large language models
so
um I took the liberty to rename the talk
uh to make it more General because
everything I'm going to be talking about
um will also hopefully translate to
other models and the experiments we did
those were done with gpt3
so
um yeah just to get started
um well
oh
sorry
um
ah here okay it was just slow okay okay
sorry
um yeah I mean as some of you might know
me from my work on Spacey
um our company explosion develops the
library and we have been since 2015
which is quite a long time ago Spacey is
an open source library for natural
language processing in Python and
um yeah it's been very popular
downloaded a lot and the its Mission has
always been to provide components and
the library for doing industrial
strength
um NLP so for production workflows
focusing on speed focusing on ease of
use and also combining
um cutting-edge machine learning
techniques with more classic war based
approaches and building pipelines for
different use cases and especially
focusing on information extraction which
is a thing in pretty much all Industries
everyone has text we have more text than
anyone can possibly read we want to find
out more about this text that goes
beyond just searching for keywords and
that's really what Spacey specializes in
and as soon as you start working with
NLP and you know you more serious about
what you're doing you pretty much always
want data you need data to train your
models you need data to evaluate your
models and that's how our first
commercial product Prodigy was born
which is an annotation tool for creating
training data and evaluation data for
machine learning models and it's really
designed as a developer tool it comes
with a command line interface with a
python library and with a UI so you can
start as a data scientist as a developer
spinning up a task creating some data
yourself running your experiments and
then scale it up with more annotators
for all kinds of different tasks from
named entity recognition text
classification
image image annotation classification
audio video pretty much anything you can
render in a browser you can annotate and
um really the focus on a developer tool
which was
um kind of new and unusual at the time
was because we really saw that you need
to be you need to develop your data data
is not static just the same way code is
not static so it really needs to be a
part of your developer workflow instead
of just something you Outsource and get
your data back so that's
um that's what we're doing and we're
currently working on a cloud version
of Prodigy that lets you work
collaboratively on your data without
compromising on the data privacy and
scriptability so you can run your own
cluster don't need to send any of your
data into the cloud or to us and yeah
there'll be an announcement soon well
pretty much almost ready uh to get it
out it's been in the works for a long
time
so that's all really exciting and yeah
like
um
probably many many of you we've also
been very excitedly following the new
developments in large language models
because especially if you're doing NLP
one problem has always been how to get
more knowledge about the world and the
language into your model like back in
the day you really had to train your
model entirely from scratch you needed
tons of data and really teach it
everything from the thing you're trying
to learn and try and extract to
um how does English work and what are
Concepts that are mentioned and that was
very tedious and then came word vectors
that was kind of nice then came better
embeddings Transformers all of this
really made a difference and now we're
really at a point where we can see that
these larger and larger models trained
on more and more data trying to predict
the next word or words really work
extremely well and not only encode
specific information but really encode a
lot about
the language and the world which is what
makes them so great so we thought hey
there must be there there are so many
interesting and exciting ways you can
incorporate them into an NLP workflow
and that's what I'm going to be talking
about today so
um first what are practical NLP
workflows one thing that's still that's
always been very popular and still is
one of the main um ways people work with
machine learning is supervised learning
and that's not necessarily that's not
um a disadvantage or a limit it's
actually kind of a feature because
if you're doing supervised learning
you'll be able you can create examples
and tell the computer exactly what you
wanted to do based on examples that's
super powerful because often if you are
actually if you have a problem you want
to solve you kind of know what you want
the computer to do and you just need a
good way to tell it so supervised
learning is really great in that respect
because you can say here here's what I
want out try to generalize and learn
representations that give me that so and
that's very powerful but of course
it means you need good data and enough
data not necessarily big big data and
millions of examples or billions or
whatever but you need very good
representative data you need to
anticipate what will go in and you need
to create that and you need to
constantly keep that up to date so
that's
um that's one of the parts
um that's tricky but that's also
something
that large language models can
potentially help with and now you might
be looking at this and thinking like
well we hear so much about these models
um won't all of this supervised learning
or training your own models and creating
these things won't that all be obsolete
uh can we just train bigger and bigger
models and random and then just have
chat GPT do everything from start to
finish and the answer is maybe for a lot
of use cases but there's still um
especially in Practical real world
applications there are still cases where
you really want to use the language
model as a tool and not as the entire
system
and um yeah that that's um especially
relevant if you have cases where
business logic comes in
um which is you know your own specific
resources for example your own
um logic that only applies to you so one
of these cases is there um or one of
these scenarios is
um are scenarios where specific is just
better the most valuable use cases or
the most value is normally in the things
that are really really specific to your
use case and not general purpose and
don't generalize well across other
things and if you have a large language
model the reason it's so great is that
it was trained on so much data that it
can give you the most likely best answer
and best text and best analysis out at
the end which is great but if what
you're interested in is kind of the
opposite then
um yeah that's that it can still only be
a part of your entire pipeline or entire
system and you always want to inject
something that makes it really specific
um to you
um the other scenario is faster is
better
um while computers are getting faster it
would be less and less of a problem to
run larger and larger models even maybe
on a laptop or in the cloud there are
still a lot of scenarios where you
really need an answer and need the full
answer in Split seconds and that's very
difficult if your model is large and
even as computers are getting faster and
models are getting larger there will
always be use cases where you want
something smaller instead instead of a
model that can do maybe a lot of things
that you're not even interested in
um so you want to have your model run on
a phone or a tiny embedded device so
maybe in the future on a ring I recently
bought like one of these smart Rings who
knows maybe that's the future maybe you
can run an llm on these but for that you
want to
um you know do some custom work to make
it faster and smaller and only focus on
what you want
next data privacy is something I
mentioned earlier it's something that's
very important for us for our tools
there's so many Industries where
um even nowadays people work on entirely
air gap machines nothing can get no
internet nothing can come in or go out
and
um people are discussing gdpr how does
that interact with models trained on
everything on the internet
and I think that's also a very important
conversation and already we see that in
our customers our user base people do
not want to send their text to someone
else's API and I think in a lot of use
cases they also shouldn't I mean patient
records Healthcare that stuff should not
go out into the world and that stuff
should also not feed back into language
models
um because potentially there's a lot
that these models can leak so there is
there is definitely work on differential
privacy and training on data without
actually using the data and that's all
very interesting research but from a
pragmatic standpoint I think for a lot
of companies it's still much better much
more effective and efficient to just do
these things in-house which means
training their own models on their data
that run in a specific environment and
not sending anything especially not at
runtime to a third-party provider so
that's also where an llm can come in for
example during the training phase or
during the creation phase but not at
runtime
and finally there also a lot of cases
where better is just better and what we
if we're looking at GPT that does a lot
to raise the floor and that's like super
cool but there are many cases where
actually what's really important is the
ceiling and a model that's like
surprisingly crazy good given that it's
not trained on something specific
is often not good enough then compared
to something that's trained for a
specific purpose and to like this up
there's some examples where yeah maybe
good enough is good enough and then
their cases like fraud detection for
example where there's there's never a
ceiling you can always be better and you
can always
um add you know go one step further and
again in these cases
um you can incorporate these models but
there's always a lot of custom work you
want to be doing to get more out of them
um so
um if you're looking at uh you know
building something with a large language
model in a loop and maybe use it to do
stuff
um automatically for you
um instead of creating training data
there are some problems
um especially when it comes to
information extraction
um that or if you want to use the data
to maybe train a smaller Downstream
model uh that you have to be aware of
and work around and one of them is
prompt engineering which is yeah pretty
Hot Topic at the moment but basically
you have this whole other variable now
which is the prompt that you feed into
the model there's a lot of research
around how to best phrase your problems
what do best
um do I think it also
um It's actually kind of non-trivial I
think it helps a lot to know how these
models work to actually also know a bit
about language to really come up with
the best possible way to prompt your
model but it means that something you
have to try out you have to test there's
no one best answer it's a lot of trial
and error and if your prompt changes
that also means the output changes so
um in the output it's easy to get
inconsistent results that's maybe also
something you've seen if you've played
um with the models it's not such a big
deal if you are the human consuming and
reading it but if you want a machine to
consume the output and read it that's
actually requires a lot more work so you
might have the a really good response um
right there but it's unstructured again
so now you're kind of back at square one
where you have to for example use NLP in
order to a um create that prompt and
then B turn that prompt into something
that you can quickly you can compute
with and the response might still be
better than anything else that um you
know you could easily train yourself but
you need to turn it into something that
a computer can work with so these are
the main problems and that's also
something we've seen in our experiments
and um yeah try to find good solutions
for because if we solve these then um
yeah we can really have a much faster
and much more efficient workflow for
creating custom models
and um so yeah one
um important aspect is definitely if we
are working with large language models
as a component
um as a tool in order to better create
data for example the process needs to be
iterative we need to be able to very
quickly try things out
um because we have the prompt change the
prompt slightly the result changes uh
need to change it to the way we're
passing the result try a different
prompt and so on try out
how about we let the large language
model return Json can that work
sometimes works well sometimes doesn't
maybe we can ask you to give us a list
maybe we can ask it to format things all
of these things really depend on a use
case and on a prompt
um so we basically needed a workflow
that made us like able to do this really
quickly and efficiently
um and also kind of store the
intermediate state of like okay here's
the code for the prompt and the pausing
um so we kind of have a record of that
and second evaluation
um is very important if not I'm not sure
I would say more important it's always
important but um it's something that's
often ignored but
um it's one thing to try out things
yourself and play around with what the
model gives you but you need a really
really stable
um evaluation you need data you still
need to create examples where you know
the answer so you can check it against
what you get from that model and
actually at the moment what makes it
sort of even more important is if you're
consuming it from an API especially from
a third-party provider open AI cohere
these models can just change and they do
change and often maybe in good ways if
there's a bug found if there's an issue
a new version is deployed and so you can
never really rely on
um getting back the same result
similarly
um you might not even be getting back
the exact same answer for the same
prompt every time so you really want to
have a stable representative evaluation
that you can run every day constantly to
make sure that you're really getting
what you're expecting and um so that's
also something yeah we needed to do we
needed to have
um a fast efficient way to create that
evaluation data and we need to be able
to run that
and uh finally
um we've also seen that in in a lot of
real world use cases
um the goal
um it doesn't make much sense to set the
goal as replacing any task specific
models and just having this one llm
magically do everything there's so many
um uh Avenues and so many so many
factors where you just want to inject
something custom that
um the most promising path at the moment
is you want to use them to improve task
specific models and get to something
that does exactly what you want much
quicker than before rather than trying
to get something bigger that um happens
to be able to do quite decent at what
you want on top of a lot of other things
and that's also yeah that's we think in
our experiments we've seen that that's
really where
um the models um are strongest and also
that's something you see at the moment
in the literature there have been
several papers
um comparing the result of
um say a GPT model to
um more tasks a more task specific model
on Benchmark data sets and we do see
that of course if you train something
for a specific purpose the results are
still significantly better and that's
not uh surprising that's um that makes a
lot of sense
um so that's also what I'm going to be
focusing on here because I think that's
also the most exciting part and it's
really the part where
um you we want to think further than
just text generation as the system I
think once you really look at it and
think past the most obvious I think
there are a lot of really
exciting and interesting
um use cases to solve real world
problems
and um yeah so what we ended up building
is scriptable workflows
um we need a human in the loop um even
if what you're doing is something that
can be done end to end by just the
language model and you're creating
something
um you still need evaluation data you
need at some point to come in and say
here are examples I know the answer to
and that won't go away and you need a
way to inject your business logic which
could be looking things up in a database
or checking
um checking things where there is a
correct answer and where you don't just
want to rely on the model potentially
hallucinating
um a correct effect which is also
something we've seen happen
so
um here's a quick diagram of our
experiments and our workflows in the
corner you can see the GitHub repo these
are all
um what Prodigy is a commercial tool the
recipes and workflows are all open
source you can look at
um the code you can also look at look at
some videos and see how it works in
practice and I'll also walk you through
some visual examples but the idea is we
start with a prompt and with a task for
example here's a text from a recipe as
in you know here's how to cook something
we've we can scrape that from Reddit and
we want to extract ingredients and
equipment and we can have an example of
that of the tech input text we can give
in as part of the prompt we can say
here's how we want you to do it list all
the all the ingredients and list all the
equipment and then we query
um a large language model for example
here gpt35 that's what we use but now
there's also gpt4 available there's chat
GPT so there are a lot of different
options and then what we get back is the
zero shot or few short response
hopefully
in a format that we can pass and that
matches the example in the prompt and
then in Prodigy we can load that in view
it visually and curate data that we want
for our task specific model so we can
correct mistakes correct inconsistencies
and we can skip examples that we don't
think I would fit and if it's all
correct we can just save it and very
quickly end up at a really good data set
and also a data set using
um yeah maybe things things we hadn't
thought of before so that's that's the
workflow and
to give you an idea roughly of how that
looks under the hood this is kind of
more of a pseudocode example because of
course if you're querying an API there's
like a bunch of boilerplate that's like
you know that I don't want to put on my
slide but the general idea is this so
Prodigy is fully scriptable so you write
your workflow as part as a python
function so the function loads your data
puts together your stream and then
Returns the components so it Returns the
name of the data set to save the
annotations to a view ID which is the
interface to use plain text named
entities image audio all of these have
like their own Json format of how you
feed in the data you give it a stream of
examples that you want to view and you
want to annotate and you can give it an
optional update callback that's called
when you receive answers back so
what we can do here in our case is in
the when you start up the recipe on the
command line we query the large language
model and pass the response so we load
in some of our Reddit examples
or any text really we asked the model
add the annotations pass them out from
the text and send it forward
and if we get examples back we can also
use them to tune the prompt if needed so
if they are if we see problems if there
is something
um that we kind of ideally want the
model to adjust to we can send it back
included in the prompt
um and then in the future we'll
hopefully get better examples or Worse
that's why you know it's iterative
because you're changing the prompt uh it
might tank the whole thing so there's a
lot of trial and error
um to use so
um here's one example I hope you can
read this
um this is how it looks like how it
looks in the UI so we can see here
because it's you know it's an iterative
process you really want to be able to
see what the prompt was what the
response was in case something goes
wrong until you've really found
something that you can scale up so we
can see here um it's actually like
really it was really rewarding and
exciting to try this out because the
model is pretty really good especially
if chosen a topic that's
um we know the model has probably the
language model has probably seen a lot
of these are all food Concepts that's
pretty common so um it's doing uh
surprisingly well and the approach here
is we give it a text and
um we're asking it to extract comma
separated lists of strings that that's
what that works quite well sometimes
yeah we've tried out different
approaches there are scenarios where it
might work to ask it to give you Json
that you can pass although it might take
some iterations to see its validation
um feels a bit hacky here one problem
you might have that you can't rely on it
to always give you
um every instance so there's still some
logic as in you know kind of basic
actually basic NLP you then have to
apply back in order to really select
these entities but it works so this was
my this was very satisfying but of
course there are also cases where it
gets it wrong it's quite subtle here's
the mistake the pens are missing in the
um
in the output so this is just an example
of well model just got it wrong it's
it's not perfectly consistent
um just like humans are not perfectly
consistent
and but what we can do in the UI is we
can manually
correct it remove the incorrect
highlight at a corrected version that's
very quick just highlighted and
still even if the model gets
um you know 10 wrong that's still
um 90 less work for you as the human and
at the same time it also gives you more
insights into what's there
um how the prompts work how the
responses work and build up a better
mental model because the truth is we're
still at a point where we don't actually
know so much about how
um you know what what really happens
under the hood and what the best way is
to get the best answer so this is a good
way to also try things out and
um what we've also built in which was
pretty cool is
um you can flag an example that's like a
built-in feature in Prodigy and we're
using that to add the correct answer to
the prompt to tune so if we are in a
scenario where we see oh the model gets
a lot wrong or this specific example is
quite important and it can't get it
right then we can add it and hopefully
um get better responses later on so
um the same works for
um a text classification as well so
that's another thing we tried out
um we give it a text and a label and we
ask
um the model to basically
um
yeah say whether we should accept this
for the category or reject it and so and
the very nice thing here is we can ask
it to generate and display a reason so
that's that could be part of the prompt
so the prompt asks is this text a recipe
and if yes why if not why and for a lot
of these things it can actually do that
um uh surprisingly well so
um because also a lot of these examples
are quite clear that's that's really
where the model is very strong at that
sort of question answering task and we
can take advantage of that and even if
it's wrong this gives you at least some
insight into
um how that prediction came about
whether it's uh yeah whether it's
correct or not and the same also works
for
um multiple answers so that's also
something that's just a different
interface in Prodigy
um we give it a multi-select pre-select
what we get from the large language
model and
um yeah here it chooses out of the three
it selects uh the category feedback
because the text is providing an opinion
about the use of cream cheese in mashed
potatoes so
um it does
um it does get it and
um yeah that's
um we're still trying out different
different workflows so
um these are just some of the examples
that were very promising
um but
um oh yeah but we can we can definitely
see this working well in a lot of other
scenarios too and I'll also show or give
a quick overview of some other things
we're working on at the moment
um along similar lines
and I think one thing uh we generally
see when working with NLP in a real
world scenario is that a lot of the
things we're trying to find out they
don't necessarily map neatly to an
end-to-end prediction problem so
um a lot of the work is in taking a
business problem that you have like
populate my database and relate these
two things to each other and then do
some maths to something do a pipeline
and two components that you can train
write code whatever and
um yeah and I think and um while a lot
of examples of having a model directly
predict the output
um are very cool it doesn't always map
neatly and most effectively to a real
world problem so here's an example I've
actually used that in several of my
talks because it's really actually quite
close to what a lot of people are trying
to do even though in different scenarios
so here we want to build a system that
takes news announcements of company
sales and extracts a nice Json
representation of all the info in it and
this is actually something that nowadays
you could try and get a large language
model to predict
um like verbatim the Json and I think it
could
and that's very um and there's a lot of
research around this and that's very
exciting but it's also
um not very modular and it's quite risky
if you're actually using this in your
system because you really have to rely
on it to Output you exactly this and if
something changes
um you have a problem so the way this is
often done in you know a practical
setting or the way I would maybe
recommend someone solve this problem is
first you want to start you start out by
deciding whether that system whether
that text is about a company's sale in
the first place because you'll get a lot
of noise no matter how good your
scraping is you'll always end up with
noise so that's the first one is it even
about that if not you discard that
that's probably quite easy to do these
days if you have some data text
classification company sale yes or no
um that probably gets you uh quite far
next you want to get the company names
out so you want to you want to find out
which companies are mentioned in the
text and the actual text they mentioned
in and then you actually want to relate
these companies to an entry in a
knowledge base you want to relate
Microsoft to The Entity Microsoft
whether on it's on Wiki data or some
other resource you might have internally
that's typically referred to as entity
linking for company names like this it's
quite easy that's all public info but
often if you yeah working something
internally in a company you might have
your own knowledge base of products and
want a link mentions to those products
and that always needs custom work but
that's something you can train
um if you have some data and some
examples
and finally stock tickers there's still
yeah your large language model could
probably do that um it might also
hallucinate your stock ticker so that's
a fact that's something that doesn't
even need machine learning
um you can look that up online and that
will be correct and that will be fast
and that's just a component you want to
add on top
um you don't want this to be part of
your whole process
um and finally price you can detect the
price you can convert it to and you want
to convert it to an amount that you can
do maths with that's also something
machine learning can do but actually I
think that python libraries that can do
it for you much more effectively
um you could that you can test there's
no need to potentially introduce
mistakes this way passing a number is
kind of solved and I'm not sure any
complex model can beat a part of the
library that you can just download on Pi
Pi so as you can see here there are two
parts of it that where I think even
right now a large language model can
absolutely help with and be integrated
as a tool which is the text
classification step I'm pretty sure you
get really good accuracy out of the box
um and if you could curate this you can
very very quickly get to a data set
that's good comprehensive representative
to train that component and even some
old-school text classification methods
they're still if you look at the
literature some even old uh even you
know a bag of words model in some cases
can really outperform your fancy uh
large Transformer model
there's like a lot a lot of low hanging
fruit there that you can take advantage
of entity recognition the same
extracting company names that's
something you can bootstrap very quickly
with a language model and then you have
a space system you can use that you can
add your business Logic on top of and
you have a robust type line that you can
test and yeah I think I'm very I'm
definitely very excited to keep
um experimenting with this because I
think this will make a lot of a lot of
in a lot of use cases the first steps
especially were the bottleneck and I
think
um we can yeah we can improve this and
make it a lot easier to solve these kind
of custom problems
and so yeah in summary here's the GitHub
URL again if you want to check out these
workflows natural language models
they're great tool for creating better
data faster and iteratively iteration
incredibly important you'll always need
task specific data there's no way around
that it's a feature not a bug it's good
you can tell a system what to do and you
need to evaluate your system you'll
always need to have the answers for at
least some of your data that's just how
it is and evaluation is good and
important
nobody yes you can definitely you can
end up at a 99 accuracy if your
evaluation is fit that's not what you
want you want a system that's useful so
you want a good evaluation and yeah
there are many applications in the
future that we don't even know about yet
and
um yeah I definitely encourage everyone
to yeah if you think once you think past
just hey here's an input window and it
generates text there's a whole other
World opening up of using a large
language model as a tool and some of the
stuff we're working on are data
structures for result parsing for
example in Spacey we have a lot of that
already so
um you know we want to if you take this
unstructured response pass it into
something useful that you can compute
with that's very cool
um workflows for robust evaluation
evaluating prompts comparing prompts a b
testing prompts that's all stuff that's
very relevant interactively testing them
and also open source models there's a
lot of cool work happening
um and I think if you become more and
more feasible to run these models
yourself locally and that's something
we're looking at and of course yeah
shout out to our team at explosion this
is the work I'm presenting is not just
my work
um that was definitely a team effort
we've had a lot of people working and
experimenting on this and
um yeah if you're interested in more
um real-world applications of our stack
NLP I also recommend checking out my
colleague Victoria's talk tomorrow at
2ish she'll be talking about building a
custom font page for the internet to
deal with information overload which is
probably something we can all relate to
um so yeah I recommend checking that out
thanks
foreign
[Applause]
large language model on the smart ring
isn't really like our future I don't
know but it's so interesting and maybe
replacing a couple of customly written
python function by one model it's like
our next nearest Future actually one
thing I haven't even mentioned here
because it didn't fit in
called
um writing code will be much easier
there are a lot of models that can help
with that and I was very excited one
thing we tried out is I think chat GPT
we asked it to write Spacey code and
we've really put a lot of work into
keeping the library backwards compatible
not breaking all the time
um having you know the same syntax and
you can do things
patterns for Spacey's rule-based matcher
which is kind of like reg X
um taken to the next level so you can
describe tokens words and attributes and
it can do that quite well so they could
be it could be use cases where you ask
it to generate your role that does
reliably what you want so there's a lot
of four cool and then just committed to
your GitHub so everything works tested
like
just awesome
so let's work for us developers sounds
very very nice do you guys have any
questions we still have time
so let me pass Mike for you
thank you for the presentation hey I was
wondering when you say that when you
have a bad example you add it to the
prompt it means that on top of the prawn
you put that exact example solved like
for instance this is an example and then
you add your request here's the question
and then I want something like this
right exactly yeah okay okay yeah and
then if if there's several let's say bad
examples probably it will
you can reach the case where the problem
limit is uh or I mean I think that's
that's an issue sure you can that's
something where the iterative you have
to try things out I don't I'd have to
also check the code how exactly we do it
but um that's one
um it is quite interesting to see the
larger context and um from being
available in gpt4 I think yeah so that's
also something you want to play around
with like imagine you could give it
annotation guidelines because that is
something you also have to write anyways
you have you need any annotations that
are perfect and consistent and for your
evaluation at least
um and so you might write a page
explaining exactly how you want stuff
annotated and how you want ambiguities
resolved stuff like should doctor be
part of the name is uh like this there's
a lot of actually if you're interested
in this we have a blog post in
collaboration with the guardian they did
like some really cool NLP work and they
also
um publish their annotation guidelines
because it's also it's journalists
thinking about language there's a lot of
edge cases even something as simple
simple as quotes
huge kind of everything is a is a kind
of worm so you write these and maybe we
can feed those guidelines to the model
as the prompt
and get
good results back that could be
um that could be quite exciting but
we'll have to see that's it's like
already knew uh yeah thanks
any more questions uh oh I believe you
was first right and while I'm going I
just remind that we are still reading
slider.com and if you are online we can
ask your questions so type it's down
thank you for the presentation
um so to my knowledge uh the terms of
use of many llms actually prevent you
from using their output to build new
models whoever reads those uh well yeah
I'm not so the question is does it
somehow not apply here or do you have a
special deal at space I mean it's this
is a legal question that has like no uh
precedent also I'm not sure if what they
actually mean is the output as in the
generated text I think that's I think
that's mostly what they probably try to
prevent because that really starts this
Avalanche of like text just being used
and here we're just asking it to create
to reply with structure about text we
already have so
I'm not sure like this this is
definitely interesting
um I mean there's also the general
copyright issue in general of like the
model and can you even use this in the
first place
I don't know I do think if you have open
source models I think the terms
um will be different I think yeah with
the commercial models sure there's like
like with many SAS tools
um there's an incentive of the provider
to cut out
um oh yeah to make people depend more
dependent on the service and cut that
out I don't know I haven't looked at the
terms in detail if that's if it's not
allowed then yes you shouldn't be you
know I think shouldn't be doing it in a
production I mean research I think is
fine you can you know you can run
anything locally
on your machine to try it out but I
think I don't think this is something
that will hold up
yeah cool you still have time for I
believe two questions
um
who was first I believe someone from
here and then I come back to you
I
think he was first but it's it's I don't
know
we are polite sorry
he was first thank you yeah I want you
to ask just two questions the first one
do you do fine tuning for your specific
cases to make large models more specific
and the second do you use some Fabrics
like uh link chain or Haystack
um so
even though it's still you know you
still end up with this large model but I
think distillation fine tuning there's a
lot of potential to cut out all the
stuff you don't need and make it more
specific and I think in the some of the
newer experiments we're running that I
haven't showed here we were using Lang
chain and mini chain which I think is a
more compact
version for the prompt management and
also there's all this stuff this
boilerplate around making API calls and
that's always great to to have someone
else solve
um and so I think especially for the
stuff we're doing with Spacey Spacey has
this config system that makes it very
easy to plug in your own functions and
that also means that yeah you can pretty
much Sub in any Library
try it out and use it as part of the
workflow and the output will still be
the same
cool
and our last question
so then are you still up to cool
yeah thanks for the talk you mentioned
the problems the Channel with these
models with inconsistency of the output
and the randomness I think and also the
not clear format yeah did you find any
like good recipes to generalize this in
a way to say like to decorate your
requests always with a certain like
surrounding either with a system
instruction or like say
independent of the question always
answer please unless that you can always
like independent of your quest wrap
around like decorate your requests with
a certain prompt that guarantees you or
like mitigates this issue yeah
yeah I think templates basically where
okay you can play around with different
ways of phrasing it then it subs in the
text that comes in and then it has like
a corresponding function that takes the
response and then passes it like if it's
a bullet point list so there is some of
that but there's still there is there
are still cases where we just kind of
have to discard what comes in like for
like there's somewhere okay it just it
just happens sometimes it mentions all
instances sometimes it doesn't
um sometimes what comes out does not map
to the original text which can still
happen and then we're just like meh the
good thing in this curation workflow you
could just skip like if you have enough
coming in you can skip but I do think
over time there will probably I hope
that there will be
more kind of best practices around this
also as the models change I at least
seems reasonable
yeah
thank you so much I believe now we are
out of time for the questions so thank
you so much for being so responsive I'll
still be around I have stickers
um yeah
thank you
[Applause]